let me just briefly uh introduce this
report I'll note it is down to councilor
Harvey do you want to briefly introduce
the report councilor Harvey no thank you
uh
excellent uh so it's uh
about London Knights Lane uh tiddington
the first paper was presented to cabinet
on the 16th of January 23 and
um
would you care to update us please
counselor on uh with pleasure um yes
um I think after the last meeting I
think we it was deferred a decision you
deferred and we went away and I'm going
to hand over to my uh friend here who is
chair of the newly constituted group in
tillington and she will fill you in on
what has been happening okay
hello my name's Louisa Smith and I'm
here just to give a brief update of work
going on behind the scenes since the
last cabinet meeting
we are now a fully formed and
constituted community group with an
elected Committee of which I am chair we
have decided collectively to name our
group while tiddington as while our main
focus is the Gravel Pit we want to put
ourselves forward to assist in other
biodiverse areas in tiddington including
an offer to assist with the forest
school at ulverstone primary
we wanted to thank cabinet for the
points put across at the last meeting
which led to a positive meeting with
Tony perks Walt Whittington believes
collectively that the recommendation put
forward by the deputy chief executive is
a beneficial approach for all making a
good business case and potential
Financial return by way of the
biodiversity offset management plan we
support the proposal being put forward
and feel that this is a positive way for
us to move forward should cabinet be in
support of this proposal we would like
to make assurances that we very much
look forward to working closely with
Stratford District Council to make this
project a success
thank you Council Ralph
and to further add to that Jonathan
Thompson has had two meetings now with
Tony perks to discuss the biodiversity
and the charges imposed on this land and
all is going forward according to their
plan
and I support fully What the residents
of chittington wish to do with this
thank you and can I just check about the
public liability insurance
um well as the land would remain an
asset of Stratford District Council it
will be covered by a Stratford District
Council public liability insurance
because the proposal that's being put
forward by Tony perks is that the land
remains a an asset of Stratford District
Council
councilor Pemberton
thank you leader
um
I think we can I'd recommend we move to
the recommendation and I'm quite happy
to uh to to propose the recommendation
there's clearly work been done officers
are clearly happy to progress that work
I think it's moved on to the next stage
let's not prolong their Agony any
further so I'm happy to propose
um I've just had an amendment to the
recommendation uh handed to me by the
chief exec
and it says delete officers be requested
and replace it with the deputy chief
executive be authorized counselor Harvey
are you happy with that Amendment
seems eminently sensible fine so I've
had a proposer uh councilor Pemberton do
I have a second
councilor Parry
thank you thank you chair
um I'm very happy to Second this
proposal and recommendation but I just
wanted to say that I thought it was
rather disappointing that Stratford Town
Council
um
decided not declined the opportunity to
get involved I think it's a great shame
because tiddington is such a Vibrant
Community as part of the Town Council
and I certainly would like to extend my
best wishes to the residents for making
this a terrific success but just wanted
to make that comment thank you chair
thank you councilor Perry I think it is
a point extremely well made
so with that our
members of cabinet happy with the
recommendation as amended great
uh sir will having a German for two
minutes if the people from tiddington
actually wish to take the opportunity to
leave
okay right
sorry
let's reconvene uh Now we move back to
item four strategic risk register
and hey this is a
[Music]
this records all significant risks to
the council's operation key priorities
and major projects
uh the strategy identifies the risk
registers should be reviewed quarterly
by the council's management team
and then twice a year by the council's
cabinet it's not surprising given
everything that's happened which could
have been clustered as a risk that this
has not been done
uh
I would say that
looking at the risks register it covers
those risks that can be identified and
there will always be unknown unknowns
that may come hurtly now to the woodwork
I do have some comments to make before
we move to a discussion uh the first is
that if we look at risk for Recruitment
and Retention of staff
there may well need to be an
identification of single points of
failure within the council
uh in terms of the existing and
implemented actions again on point four
there is an HR strategy being developed
which I think is a good action to take
on item five under existing and
implemented actions I would point to the
strong support
for the University Warwick Innovation
campus stratford-on-avon
when we get to item 8 inability to
respond to an emergency first in our
communities and these comments actually
come as a result of a session
that I attended at the district
council's Network annual meeting
and it is really important that to note
that we have a cohesive management team
which is really important and that we
actually have people in the building
which is also very important it was
interesting the comment that was made at
the conference about the experience with
the grandfather fire that an awful lot
of the people working for that
particular Council had a long way to
travel to get in
so with those comments from me members
of cabinet do you have any comments or
[Music]
any items for discussion about this
paper
Council junid
these are all a risks that are
particularly strategic
um I'd like to kind of make sure that
they this is not a one-off that there
are they are reviewed at appropriate
times probably through the overview and
scrutiny or some similar but there are
two a couple uh that had particularly
um would like to to address one is about
the safeguarding children and vulnerable
adults and although it's the County
Council that has the social services
there is a lot of that the district
council can do in partnership with
others and I am concerned about that
because I I've had instances reported to
me
um that that caused me concern
um the the other one is that I
particularly would like to have a
feedback on after the event as well is
the performance on the day of um how
voter ID actually works and make sure
that we get a response about where and
how
um it you know people have had
difficulties I would particularly like
to know if there is any instances at all
where voters are turned away because of
lack of voter ID or of appropriate
locality a voter ID because it might
mean that we've not got the
communications right we do need to make
sure that everybody I know you're doing
a communication
um uh strategy Communications to all all
voters but I think if there are any
problems we we might need to review it
to make sure that that could be improved
councilor Barker
can I just ask councilor junid to
clarify what she means that she has a
safeguarding concern because that makes
my head swivel
with concern I don't like to go into
individual cases but I have certainly
got a couple of cases that I'm dealing
with in where Housing Association The
Plea and police
are involved and where there are young
people and drugs potentially could be
serious issues so it's just maybe at
another time out of this meeting I could
speak to an appropriately that would be
a really good idea the only thing I I
need to say about that is really what
the responsibility we have at the
council we have um certainly and I'm
sure Mr Platts will back me up on this
but we have improved
um considerably the amount of work we do
on safeguarding um and on flagging it up
to individuals so that there is more
awareness of it but I'm concerned if
you've got if you have a concern with
the Housing Association I'll certainly
be all over it like a rash thank you
councilor Pemberton and then councilor
Harvard
okay counselor Harvey
thank you Mr chairman can the former
returning officer
confirm that it would be a normal
operational consideration post an
election for the Democratic services
manager to provide you with a report
about what went well what didn't go well
and what needed to change
I would have thought
I would have anticipated that would be a
routine matter and in this particular
case given that we have the new uh
requirement for photo ID I would assume
that that would automatically be covered
regardless is that the case
Mr Brooklyn chairman thank you thank you
for the question yes the auditing
standards committee receiver post
election review following elections this
is a particular risk that we're facing
this year with the voter ID and and I'm
sure that will be part of the report
that is reported to that committee
so the reality is that will be covered
by routine operations
yes it is it's already part of the
planned report but I do I do accept that
voter ID for this particular election is
something that's new and would be a big
part of that report that goes to the
audience science committee
thank you Mr Buckland so I see no
further questions the options available
to Cabinet are endorse the Strategic
risk registered appendix one subject to
where the Amendments protein uh endorse
a strategic risk register of appendix
one and agree alternative mitigating
actions so that's covered what I said
and two one three reject the Strategic
risk register so are we happy to endorse
uh two one two
okay thank you members of cabinet so
moving on electric vehicle
infrastructure in South Warwickshire The
Way Forward uh
counselor where's he gone Fleming
people providing an overview of
procurement approaches available to the
council reference Council and or say to
Warwickshire includes both Stratford and
Haven District and Warwick District
Council to facilitate an increased
provision of electric vehicle
infrastructure across the district and
to provide an understanding of the
opportunities available within the
responsibilities of South Warwickshire
and a proposed Way Forward
this is which has been discussed at
length about various styles of of
charging Point
um and the sites where these things may
well be placed
um
and after looking at the the various
options that are available to us
um
we've the recommendation is to agree to
procure South War extra feasibility
study at a maximum cost of 40 000 with
SDC share to be funded from the climate
change budget to establish how the
Cancer's portfolio of electric vehicle
charging location can best be delivered
best deliver the outcomes it is
recommended that the study Builds on the
work of
work undertaken to date assess the
financial potential of the different
contract options for the council
estimates the charge session numbers
across the County's portfolio of sites
profit and revenue assuming the specific
electricity rates and evcp tariffs are
within
pounds per kilowatt hour
and reviews the council sites including
ownership parking restrictions number of
parking Bays
advises the full cost implication of
installing charging infrastructure
investigates the challenges and
possibilities of a collaboration on a
joint procurement exercise between
Stratford and Warwick ensures any
proposals that meet key outcomes
are outlined in section 1.7 of the
report
and that's that takes me to the end of
the recommendation
thank you councilor Fleming Mr folks
Skinner do you have anything to add to
that
uh no thank you I can't see the room so
apologies I can't see the room hopefully
you can see and hear me um no that was
succinct enough
um we we've got a lot to offer
um
a electric vehicle providers in
southwest and I want to make sure that
we get it right
um hence the reason for the feasibility
study we need to know what we can offer
the market
I've done a fair bit of work so far but
we also we but we do need to know and
what we've got to offer the different
procurement options available to us
um and there is a set of outcomes as
part of the report that I believe that
we ought to be following
um Equity of distribution is important
um I think we need to provide
um charges in places where it may not be
necessarily profitable but the idea is
that you can offset the profitable sites
against the the ones that necessarily
aren't going to be profitable but that
will ensure an equity of distribution
across the area
so no thank you unless anybody's got any
questions thank you Mr folk Skinner and
I would endorse what you say I think
this is far more complex than it may
appear on the surface councilor Pember
thank you just for clarity I'm assuming
that this is the same report that's
going to Warwick because we're procuring
this on a joint basis
yeah the same thing yeah we're basically
just being asked to to sign off on the
feasibility study and that to help give
us the answers to drive things from
there yeah yes that's right yep thank
you thank you uh councilor shenton
it's a very quick one I'm assuming that
the the split is a 50 50 split between
US 20
000 each yeah yes yeah thank you thank
you very much thank you
councilor junid
just to say that um I I do support it
but I have to say that I'm a driver of
an electric vehicle so and have been
since 2013 so just to declare an
interest on that one but I have had um
through various uh working groups that
have before this and have made various
points which have been taken on board
and thank you for that so I do support
um
in the report it says being in well-lit
um places for the for the charge points
for example which is particularly
relevant to a female driver as well as
as well as a male driver
um that it should be in well-lit areas
and some of them are not currently but
one of the points that is not addressed
that can't see that it's addressed but
it may be I may have missed it is
whether or not we could reduce the
number of apps at the moment I think
I've got five apps different apps for
mobile chargers
um across the country and um if we could
possibly find a way of um standardizing
that or having contactless whether
that's something that has to be
addressed at a national level I don't
know but that would certainly reduce The
Angst for a lot of us who are electric
car drivers thank you but just to make
it clear I support the project
thank you yes I think that is probably
an interesting point for negotiation Mr
folk Skinner do you wish to comment on
that particular point
I noticed the rise smile incidentally
no you're absolutely right I mean I'm
the same as councilor junid in that
you've got a you've got your phone full
of apps which is not particularly
convenient but um the the government
grants that there is government moves to
actually make
um a requirements of uh contactless
payment for Grants so there are various
grants that you can go for for electric
vehicle infrastructure and it will be
fairly soon I've told that it will be
they will only be able to get those
grants if it's contactless so that would
be my aim yes
um going from a point of view of world
lit and inviting they need to meet the
there is new standards for accessibility
and ideally also contactless whether
that can be happened straight away or
whether we can it is possible but that
would be my aim yes is to have it
contact us so that you're not having to
put another app on your phone
thank you Mr folks again good news
indeed for those people who drive an
electric car
um
so
yes councilor kettle
um
will the review also look at the supply
of electricity into South Warwickshire
because clearly that is that is quite a
key part of delivering a vehicle
charging Network which I assume will
cover the east in particular will it be
coming to my ward and pick up sitchinson
I hope
um but
um I know Mr Focus Center comes from
Bishop Washington very interesting
question councilor Kettle Mr folks
Skinner can you respond to that
yes I mean certainly part of there are
areas of South Warwickshire where it
isn't served by um
uh at one of our assets so the for
example mostly in Stratford districts
but there are areas where we haven't got
a car park and okay well what what do
you do what do the local communities do
for about charging so I've been
exploring
um we've uh Village Hall uh Parish
Council Village halls with with the
potential for using them as potential
small hubs for for charging in their car
Parks um I've gone through walk
um and I've got four pilot sites um that
have put their hands up and wanting to
work with myself and the energy saving
trust to look at the options for using
car parks in Village Halls
um and if golf I can't speak for Bishop
City but certainly southam is one of
those the southern Town Council have put
their hand up and wanted to work with us
with regards to the supply of
electricity the feasibility study
effectively what you're doing is you
give a consultant a the sites if you
like so you give them a car park and you
ask system they'll go through various
criteria and one of the criteria is
availability of electricity I mean
clearly
um
if if a particular car park hasn't got
it hasn't got a decent Supply that that
from the cost point of view that may
preclude it for for the time being but
it will what it will do is highlight
those areas I've got
the report does show a hierarchy of car
Parks as it stands now with
um and part of the criteria for that
hierarchy is electricity availability so
I know roughly what the availability of
electricity is for our car Parks but
what will happen with this feasibility
study it will include specifics down on
a granular level down to that particular
car park so if we would Street and sell
them if we wanted to look they would
look at the the footfall they would look
at the
um the amount of usage and they would
also include
um
the the available electricity because if
you've got if you're talking slow
charges obviously doesn't need so much
but if if it's more applicable to have a
fast charger in there
that will need a bit more power behind
it so that's part of the feasibility
study it would look at the uh each car
park or each site and look at the
availability of electricity
thank you Mr folks Skinner uh councilor
Barker and then Mr Grafton
has already done this and also has their
own solar panels on the roof of it and I
would have thought that that getting
those two ideas together would be most
helpful and I would suggest that your
contacts don't enforce if you haven't
already
thank you Mr Grafton
um so first of all I'm going to Grant a
dispensation to participate in this
discussion and vote to any decision
maker in the room who happens to have an
electric vehicle
on the basis that there are sufficient
numbers of people in the general
population who share a similar interest
also just turning to the recommendations
can I suggest that
the opening words be that subject to
Warwick District Council agreeing the
following recommendations on similar
terms to agree to procure Etc
and also in the second line when we talk
about
um 40 000 pounds with SDC share I hear
it's 50 percent
so if we could have wording that
clarifies the share at 50 that would be
I suggest useful as well thank you
I think those are very useful
suggestions uh Mr Grafton
um
I would say that one of the issues in
this whole electoral electric vehicle
infrastructure is going to be the
capacity of the grid to supply
electricity and it is really rather
interesting that again the district
council's Network annual conference
Oxford city council are running into
very similar issues in terms of because
they've got a very ambitious uh scheme
to put electric vehicle infrastructure
charging infrastructure in place and
they are running into issues with the
supply of electricity so that is not to
be underestimated so with that and
subject to the amendment to the
recommendation proposed by Mr Grafton
are we happy with the recommendations on
page 33 members of cabinet
thank you members of cabin
on item seven capital budget monitoring
I believe this is councilor Harvey
thank you chairman happy to introduce
this one
purpose of this paper is to keep members
informed of progress made over the first
10 months of the year in undertaking the
council's intended level of capital
expenditure this year table two on page
50 demonstrates the intention now to
undertake expenditure of 17 million
pounds this year including section 106
projects
whilst the amended capital expenditure
budget has remained unchanged since the
last report in January further capital
of 1.7 million pounds has been spent or
allocated since the end of period 8.
current position for the year to date as
a whole is attributable in very large
measure to the decisions to enter into
the new waste disposal contract with
biffer the cost of new AV Equipment in
the council chamber and to fund
improvements of the equipment within the
district's Leisure centers
if all the council's budgeted capital
expenditure as reported in table 1 on
page 49 that is 17 million pounds were
to be delivered the council's remaining
accumulated Capital receipts and grants
to the end of March 2023 are estimated
to be 3.9 million pounds
paragraph 1.4 indicates that capital
expenditure of 8.7 million pounds has
already been undertaken or committed by
the end of January
in the first 10 months of the year
therefore the sums spent or committed
amount to 51.1 percent of this year's
available budget of 17 million pounds
appendix 2 provides summary information
concerning the various projects yet to
be funded through section 106 agreements
totaling 8 million pounds and those
where section 106 funds have been
committed of 950 000 pounds
appendix 2 also shows that 2.7 million
pounds of community infrastructure Levy
funds have now been committed to various
projects around the district in Welford
Ulster Stratford ilmington napton on the
hill shipston Salford priors Mayan Vale
Morton Merrill Morton Warren and lytorn
and upper right horn
I asked there for Mr chairman that the
current position on capital expenditure
and income for the period to the end of
2023 January 2023 be received
thank you counselor Harvey are there any
questions or discussion members of
cabinet uh I see no hands raised so in
that case we received the report
agreed thank you members of cabinets so
moving on uh Revenue budget monitoring
uh councilor Harvey
thank you Mr
chair the purpose of this report is to
inform the cabinet of the revenue
picture of the council's finances to the
end of January 2023.
I'd like to begin by asking members to
turn to appendix 3 on page 77.
this shows the net budget to be financed
by the council this year is now 16.6
million pounds
if we now turn to appendix 2 on page 75
we can see that the budget for the whole
year is for total expenditure of 34.6
million pounds and total income from
various sources of 18.4 million pounds
the difference between these two numbers
I.E 16.2 million pounds together with
the net cost of benefits of 291 000
pounds represents the total amount to be
funded from various sources in other
words 16 and a half billion pounds as
set out in appendix 2.
in addition appendix 2 also sets out in
the second table on page 75 the income
that the council has received I.E the
net civil contingency funding from the
government in relation to the covid-19
pandemic and the various schemes through
which the staff of the revenues and
benefits team have distributed These
funds in ways consistent with the
government's intentions leaving at the
end of January a balance of 1.8 million
pounds
turning to the position at the end of
period 10 we can see that on page 75 in
round terms the council's actual and
committed expenditure of 29 and a half
million pounds was 2.4 million more than
budgeted almost exactly the same
position as was the case at the
corresponding point last year
this reflects a variety of Management's
decisions across the council's activity
in light of the current change
circumstances and the impact of events
these results also reflect a number of
decisions to initiate some planned
expenditure on the basis that it would
be financed by the release of funds that
had previously been earmarked for this
purpose
on the other hand income for the 10
months to January was budgeted to be
14.5 million pounds was similarly by 3.5
million pounds and totaled sorry was
similarly exceeded by 3.5 million pounds
and totaled 18 million pounds as members
of the cabinet will be all too aware
this reflects in considerable part to
the unanticipated level of interest
earned on the campus rules cash balances
the overall position therefore is that
the net outcome of the council's
activities to the end of January was a
surplus of 722 000 pounds more than had
been budgeted or put it another way the
Surplus from the council's activities to
the end of January was six percent above
the budgeted figure
section 2 of the paper together with
appendix one provides estimates for the
outturn for the year in full of a
favorable position of one million and
one million pounds and seventy three
thousand
Section 3 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance from their
budgeted figures During the period April
to January
managers and heads of service
responsible for their respective budgets
are to be commended for their providing
their estimates in the face of
continuing uncertainty surrounding the
council's activities
section six of the paper demonstrates
based on the estimated outcome for the
financial year as a whole together with
movements between the council's reserves
the general Reserve account the key
measure of the council's financial
health will increase in round figures
from 8.5 million pounds at the beginning
of the year to 10.3 million pounds at
the end
importantly appendix 4 identifies the
council's current earmarked reserves as
they stood at the end of January 2023
the council's earmarks reserves are kept
under review by the management team as a
matter of routine and sound management
practice
subject to any further information that
Mr Burrell might be in a position to
provide about the prospects for the
remainder of the current Financial year
and to any questions members may have I
ask that the report be received thank
you Mr chairman thank you councilor
Harvey uh
canceled unit are you able to let me
know what the position will be with the
Civil contingencies funding with Will
government require you know that any
money not spent to go back to them
what's their actual position at the
moment for that fund
quite happy to defer to Mr Burrell but I
think the answer to that is it's not our
money it's the government's money
they'll have it back eventually
yeah I just like to clarify that is the
position there are about 25 schemes that
we're gradually working through a
Reconciliation process so
still quite a long way to go but any
unspent money that we've been given will
be returned
I think it
councilor Parry
uh thank you chair I was just interested
with regard to the refuse collection
whether the unfavorable variance of 205
000 included any any sort of
compensation that was going to come back
from biffer or if if that had been
agreed later down the line
thank you councilor Perry uh
us councilor Harvey do you want to
respond that is an operational question
of detail which I don't possess
uh right okay it might be worth just uh
letting councilor Perry know uh
presumably you could do that Mr burrow
I will do yes yeah
councilman kettle
I'm not going to go into great detail Mr
chairman but um recharges to other
accounts uh in the 10 months today to
2.3 million which we've been told before
is actually transfers from Reserves
um and I'd like therefore to go to the
schedule on transfer to reserves or
transfer tool from Reserves which is
appendix 4
and I can't see a figure on that page
that correlates with a figure in
appendix 2.
um
I have brought this issue up on a number
of previous occasions
um
and I think you know we do need to get
an understanding between what has been
transferred from reserves into uh
income and expenditure so that we can
have a clear understanding of both what
is being spent out of Reserves
and where reserves are being
um
removed because they're not necessary
and therefore not actually being spent
at all and there is quite a difference
between money going out and an
accounting change
I would just point out on appendix 4
that
the script
I think could be improved
in that we do have items which will be
spent in the Autumn of 22 we are now in
Spring of 23.
um and where we have
um
I I think the whole detail issue needs
to be revamped because I'm not going to
go through all the detail in there but
it is not clear
and it'll be much more helpful if that
table did set out exactly two things
what is being spent
why it is being spent
and where a reserve is no longer being
needed
why it is no longer needed and I think
that would be very helpful to go forward
so there are actually two columns there
thank you councilor Kettle uh Mr Burrell
do you wish to respond or do you need
time to analyze that and get back to
counselor Kettle all right I will take
some time to take on what uh councilor
Castle said and I'll go back to him
thank you thank you Mr burrow
so
the recommendations on page 65 and I
would just say that it is uh really good
news that our finances are in a healthy
position I see the latest publication
appears to indicate the latest is it a
municipal Journal there are now two more
local authorities in financial
difficulties uh one is woking and the
other is Southampton fortunately thanks
to Improvement management we are a long
way from that recommendations on page 65
can I have your agreement members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet so moving
on we have Performance Management
framework 2324 proposed key performance
indicators councilor Parry
thank you chair this report presents the
key performance indicators and
monitoring arrangements for 23 24 and
whilst we have an election in May these
can be amended accordingly by the new
Administration later in the year
there are a few proposed changes which
include the number of visits to the
district as SDC has no control over the
number of visitors however this will be
closely monitored through our
particularly close Association as
directors with Shakespeare's England
other changes reflect the percentage of
disabled facilities Grant DFG the
applications by a new heart performance
indicator which makes a lot more sense
in addition it is proposed that a new
indicator is introduced for the number
of Home Choice
plus applications activated and the
average time in terms of days it takes
from being ready to process an
application to activation this is in
addition to the existing Home Choice
plus indicator
personally I would like to see the
target of seven and a half days
sick days per full-time employee be
driven down to six and a half days in a
bid to increase productivity having just
returned from holiday yesterday I was
unable to attend the cabinet Forum to
highlight that or give a proper response
I appreciate seven and a half days is
pretty standard in the public sector but
I think particularly in the move with
hybrid form of working it would be good
to have a focus of trying to drive that
number down bearing in mind I'm fully
aware of numbers of staff on long-term
sickness but apart from that please can
I invite you to support this report and
happy to answer any questions where
possible councilor Pemberton
thank you I'm I'm happy to support the
proposed key performance indicators I'll
just make a commentably conservation uh
it won't be the first time that cabinet
will have heard me talk about
four months around disabled facilities
Grant applications
just as a heads up
I'm going to be keeping a really close
eye on this and we all share the the
desire to move this on
um and I accept we are where we are but
we do have to ensure that the delivery
by the partnership is much closer to
that which uh residents should expect
um and I that is an operational detail
before councilor Harvey reminds me but
just when it comes to it be ready for
the questions
uh thank you councilor Pemberton Mr book
thank you chairman I just want to make a
comment in relation to the performance
of the number of sick days per year
we're unlikely to hit the seven and a
half days sickness it during 22 23 the
last information I had is like in like
it's likely been just over eight days in
the current year we've seen quite a
significant number of long-term sick and
for a small organization long-term sick
does have a disproportionate impact but
we've also had quite a significant
increase this year in the number of ear
nose and throat infections post covid so
people have been quarantining themselves
keeping themselves healthy during the
covert pandemic and now those kind of
regular infections viral infections have
increased I will say that seven and a
half days is better than the The
Benchmark in in local authorities but of
course if if cabinet are minded to
produce that six and a half days so that
gives a a very stretching Target for us
to achieve
thank you Mr Brooklyn uh so I see no
further questions her recommendation on
page 81 that the key performance
indicators and targets be approved can I
have your agreement members of cabinet
great so in that case we move on to item
10 funding of events councilor Parry
again
thank you chairman
um as you all know the local economy was
significantly hit through covid and is
still very much in recovery
um the purpose of this paper is to
stimulate the local economy and provide
essential funding support to a number of
events
the four events proposed in the paper
will enhance the image hospitality and
tourism tourism offer of both
stratford-upon-avon and The Wider
District in particular these include the
hosting of the grand Depart of the
women's cycle tour the Stratford
literary festival and an event support
Grant which I think will be particularly
good for smaller events together with
the street art and empty shops
initiative with which I see as being a
vital Catalyst to enhance the current
situation we have in the town so perhaps
I can ask for your support to continue
to drive tourism business not just to
Stratford but the wider District thank
you chair
thank you councilor Perry
any questions Council shenton just a
quick observation I fully support this
um
and in particular the street art we have
far too many properties around the town
that are empty and the town is looking
scruffy in places and this could only
improve it
thank you for your upcoming councilor
junid
um is there are there any plans to
engage with the owners of some of those
very large buildings that are empty
particularly within stratford-on-avon
but in other towns as well is there
anything you know that is being prepared
for that
um
quite a lot of that is already happening
councilors unit
thinking in particular the BHS building
is is just does not look sad really does
look sad
I mean I can specifically talk about the
BHS building so you're absolutely right
um and alongside John careford I've had
a number of discussions with the owners
of that building about trying to find a
way for that building to come back into
use
um and I think it would be fair to say
that we have been both flexible and
Innovative in our reviews and approach
to how they solve that building's uh
future
what we have been able to do is we have
used our powers in relation to the how
the site looks so particularly the
listed part of the building there's been
some work to ensure that that's been put
back in but
um
short of compulsively purchasing the
building which is not
it's unlikely that we'd be able to find
ourselves in a position where we could
meet the threshold of you know the
greater public good we have to have a
dialogue with the owner of the building
and all that we can do is to say that
you know we are open to
um discussions about innovative
solutions and indeed would welcome
innovative solutions for that particular
site but that also translates through to
other sites and we've had discussions
around some of uh some potential retail
opportunities and we'll continue to do
so but it is a competitive market out
there particularly retail can make its
choices so we've got to be smart about
it
I think it also been involved in some of
those discussions counselors unit and at
the moment things are not very
straightforward given what's happening
to the prices of property
it actually creates a problem where
assets can be held on balance sheets at
prices that no longer reflect the market
so we have we are trying we have tried
and we will continue to try but things
are not straightforward so with that
page 89
sorry
councilor Kettle absolutely support Mr
Professor what I'd like to know is
whether the portfolio Holder will be
taking part in any of the events
um in particular as I don't know what
our artistic qualities like but I'm sure
she can ride a bicycle whether you'll be
taking part
can I confirm to uh councilor Kendall
not Kettle Kettle yes
yeah I am bit jet lag
um that I can ride a bicycle and and
yeah uh not sure whether I should be
taking part but I have I think I need a
little bit of time to get back into
training
I I think leaving into being able to
ride a bicycle counselor Parry is about
right
so without without further Ado then the
recommendation on page 89
um members of cabinet happy to support
that
agreed thank you members of cabinet so
swiftly on issues arriving from
overviewing scrutiny councilor Crump
thank you Mr chairman yeah John keep
this brief
um
yeah I like some old chunky bit of bread
um there was a couple a couple of items
uh startle meeting regarding a point of
order uh around the expectations of
attendance support further holders at
osc and I think that will be for the new
Administration to decide how that should
go forward obviously there's some debate
about this
um and I'll just leave it there for for
people to
to cogitate on we talked about the
housing strategy action plan and lots of
things were reliant on responses and
actions from the County Council
and osce was happy to support in contact
in the County Council
um so we can actually prompt responses
because sometimes we won't get in SDC
won't get responses from the County
Council and obviously we want to work
together in ensure on homelessness is
responded to promptly inefficiently so
um but yeah Renata is here and she did a
really good job and even if she wasn't
here I'd say she would have gave a
really good report as well so
but be careful people stand sitting
behind you we're nice and we pick
excellent thank you counselor Crump
admirably succinct OS and again there's
a couple of wings
um home housing repairs and strategy new
obligations for local authorities
especially regarding damp mold and con
condensation
and increases workload from legislation
changes again
um I think we're gonna have to ask
cabinet to consider resource and
implications for this increase in
workload and the only other one is that
um osc are likely to ask a registered
social landlords to come back or to come
um orbit have been once and we will be
asking the others to come back and give
us some ideas on how they can make our
lives residence lives easier and how
they're tackling things like that modern
condensation anti-social behavior and
things like that so they do some good
work work in partnership with ourselves
in the county so yeah I think it's all
about talking and and potentially
holding them to account uh or
challenging them when they don't always
admit their performance standards
thank you councilor councilor Barker do
you want to come in at this point just
wanted to say something
both councilor Jefferson and I have
chaired um osc so we feel your pain
councilor Crump
um however when we introduced the
uh ability of osc to ask for portfolio
holders to come the understanding was
that this was a fairly Innovative and
new way of doing things because it
didn't happen in the past
and what has now what started as a way
of
scrutinizing or overviewing what we were
doing
um has become
particularly with an election pending
um very much more political I think than
we ever hoped that it would be it was
merely to open up a dialogue and I'm not
convinced that that is necessarily how
osc is now being used I would say on the
housing
um
matters all those things are going
through and I know that you have that
you had an officer to answer the
questions on issues that had already
gone through cabinet been agreed thank
you
thank you
councilor adjunied just that I am the
vice chair and um I have been for a
while under under a couple of other
um one thing that I do feel it is in the
Constitution that you know there is a
procedure to be followed the process to
be followed perhaps it's a matter of
um timetabling that but there is a
process it is crucial there is guidance
from the
um the Institute I can't remember the
institute for
um scrutiny Etc that on how we conduct
our
um overview and scrutiny and it is about
overview as well as scrutiny and I do
hope that
um you know
that that is taken you know as as part
of the
the disease part of the making sure that
the council is working better uh and
should be taken in that heart
councilor Pemberton thank you and then I
really want to move on after councilor
crumps had his set
um
um I just make a short comment um
democracy's hard work
um and I think part of what councilor
Barker is saying is that some of that
hard work needs to be done by
overviewing scrutiny committee
um I've rocked up and
been asked to give a strategic overviews
I provide information you ask for
questions in advance to be able to be in
a position where you can provide
rational well thought through answers in
conjunction with the officers bearing in
mind the officers deliver on the ground
and we we take the sort of strategic
overview if you will so part of my
please guys you if you want to get the
best out of these sessions you've got to
start putting some harder work into
planning for them because sometimes and
too often they go off at a tangent and
you and cabinet members are being
expected to answer things off the hoof
counselor Crump yeah I would say I think
councilor junior said she's been Vice
chair to a number of chairman recently
she's got to say the latest one is the
best I think she was meant to say
um but seriously yeah I take on
take on councilor pemberton's point
about questions in advance and since
I've been chairman I've ensured there is
at least one member of the committee has
sent questions in advance and I know
Council the curses does that as well
whilst each year as well
um but you know there are
we we do try and do that sometimes I
take them there should be we should be
doing some more homework in advance and
preparing as well but there are
sometimes there are questions that are
generated on the day so yeah it's a
mixture so right
uh so moving swiftly on we have to note
the cabinet work program and then we
have one item urgent business
which is local Authority housing fund uh
Council about
yes uh Mr Buckland will now explain why
this is urgent thank you chairman and
thank you for agreeing to take the
Urgent item this afternoon the reason
for urgency for this report relates to
the time the extremely tight time scales
which the government have set the
council under the local Authority
housing fund will require to make a
response by the the 15th of March and
this was the last opportunity that we
had thank you Jim
Mr Grafton
technically chairman you have to agree
the reason if you're happy to agree that
as a reason thank you I am more than
happy to agree the reason Mr Grafton
so so
councilor Barker
I agree this is an urgent motion
piece of business as well
um
this uh the local Authority housing fund
came through
um with amazing alacrity for something
delivered by the government expected to
be delivered by a local Authority and
our officers have made haste to get
together the correct model and approach
for us to use potentially in Stratford
in this District we have
um been incredibly kind
and generous with the people who are
genuine refugees who we have helped
house so
[Music]
we haven't got syrians on the list here
but perhaps they should be added
um but those from the Ukraine and
Afghanistan in particular
who have sought refuge in this country
we know that some of the relationships
where people are staying
they didn't know how long they were
going to be here from the Ukraine but
actually they've been here perhaps
longer and they may be here even longer
and we have people from Afghanistan who
are still accommodated in a hotel so
there are moves which the government has
put has put money into to allow people
to move on through the housing system
and so the fund offered by the
government and I hope I've got this
right it's 2.35 million which is 40 of
the funding and 60 of the funding will
come from a Housing Association
um as uh once the memorandum of
understanding as per recommendation
three has been agreed the only financial
implication for us as a district council
is the contingency fund of 750 000
pounds which we've got I was going to
say sloshing around we haven't it's in
the section 106 unallocated affordable
housing funds
um so that backs it up nicely it looks
it looks
at first blush as though we are
potentially going to be providing
housing for people which may cause some
consternation but this is very separate
housing that would never have been
provided without the government
providing its chunk of funding without
our officers working so hard with the
Housing Association so
we've acted fast that money was for the
taking and we've taken it it means that
there will be more houses delivered in
this District which is a really really
good thing I for one don't want to see a
queue of homeless
ukrainians or Afghan afghanis outside
the doors and so
um
as Mr butland and I agreed this is
actually the true definition of a
no-brainer that we should take the money
we should do this and we should get on
with it and can I just say to the
officers who are here and those who
aren't who may hear it from the ones who
are
what a great job to do this so fast and
to turn it around so fast so thank you
very very much
and the recommendations you'll find on a
separate piece of paper which has come
through which I'm not going to go
through I'm sure you'll have questions
thank you councilor Barker I have to say
I thought this was a very well written
and clear paper
uh I think the reality actually is
getting two 2.35 million from the
government for 17 homes uh is a good
deal
um
so without further Ado any discussions
councilor Pemberton and then Council
I was just going to say in the in the
absence of the brain I'm going to Second
this
councilor Junior
just to say uh uh I I backed this as it
is needed and to thank the staff for the
work that they've done on this one
um I think they've done a lot more work
than probably has been done at central
government on this kind of subject but
thank you thank you thank you thank you
for doing the work right the
recommendations are on this sheet of
paper for the avoidance of any doubt so
are people happy are members of cabinet
happy with recommendations one to four
on the sheet of paper
thank you members of cabinet